hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round three of
the 20/20 candidates tournament it's a
key relaxing called the wild card
against an opponent and it's a it's a
really exciting game really wild opening
as you might imagine but such things are
to be expected when when an opponent is
playing
for example and we will also check out
this nice forum you've seen in the
thumbnail so let's just enjoy that for a
second courtesy of Mario Emiliano
fortress calm there we have it the the
nice elbow bump before the game starts
you can see that they're having a really
awesome time and I'm sure that it in
some way it did impact the game the
players being in such a good mood which
you will see so let's check it out
and before this actual game we're not
gonna show their head-to-head score
because there isn't any they only played
one game so far it was in it in 2018
world blitz championship that nipple one
with the black pieces with a with a very
nice night of game which is probably why
here now after Alex saying opened with
e4 he didn't go for let's say c5 done I
don't he went for east sex nipple goes
for the friendly defense as probably he
expected that because they already
played that one game in the night of
that Alex & Co prepared something for
him so instead he said okay let's just
try the French now we have d4 d5 Knight
to c3 and Bishop to b4 the V number
variation with E 5 advancing the pawn in
the now c5 so this is also a very
standard with a three and now Bishop
captures and c3 the mainline in in case
someone plays Bishop to a5 against you
just so you know you can just go for b4
it's it's the way to go
now for example seek out Chris Knight b5
you go after the d6 square and now why
should always be better for example b3
check you're gonna block check and now
most likely people will play something
like Bishop to c7 but whatever they play
you will have a you will have a nice
game for example if Bishop c7 you're
gonna capture here and if they take away
your knight you just capture capture
continue developing night is coming to
e2 you can Castle a for Bishop coming to
a3 and you will just have a nice game
just in case someone tries this against
you but
here nipple goes for the main line
Bishop captures on c3 with V captures
and now Knight to e7
and although Queen to g4 is by far the
most popular line here nipple includes
h4 so it's like alpha zero
revolutionized chess in every opening
now there's the inclusion of h4 and h5
because if alpha zero place it it must
be good
so Queen to c7 now putting pressure
under on the C file as these two points
could be could become weak in some lines
and now Knight to f3 just saying that
there's no real danger here of you
actually doing anything if captures
captures Queen sees recheck there's
nothing black is just wasting time
everything's nicely defended you have to
go back rook c1 if anything you just
helped why to develop pieces
so after Knight of three b6 are
preparing to develop the light square
bishop and then now Bishop to b5 by
nipple with Bishop to d7 blocking ending
out Bishop the back to e 2 you could
also just go a 4 you could play Bishop
d3 but alex angkor prefers Bishop to a2
and now Bishop to a four by nipple it's
a very important move prevents a4 as
white would definitely enjoy putting his
dark square bishop on this diagonal and
also you kind of pressure c2 for example
there could be some threats of captures
captures and Queen captures and c2 now
and there is one game in the database
we're up to a 2 was played to just help
out with the defense of the c2 point but
here alex angkor shows that he came very
well prepared for this line he just
castles here and now the point is you
can't really go for the sea to pawn do
do you know why it's impossible to do it
for example captures captures and Queen
captures here even feel free to pause
video as it's a nice idea so just so you
so you understand it better so for those
of you who were able to do it I'm sure
all of you saw so why that's so I'm just
gonna congratulate everyone it's
captures captures Queen captures and now
of course Bishop to b5 check that's why
it's impossible now you either capture
the bishop and you lose the Queen or you
block check let's say Knight b6 and then
just Bishop capture Sunday 4 wins apiece
here you're just down a PC there's
nothing for you to do characters captors
and/or real characters for that matter
and you're just a puppies
so after this castles an epic just
continues in Knights to d7 and here
Bishop to e3 now it's a bit a bit of a
different story because there is no
check but still captures characters and
characters you will just trade here
characters captures rook fc-1 and you
will get grabbed hold of the eater c7
square or after the bishop moves Bishop
to e6 and black will not be able to use
the C file and well why it just has
excellent compensation for the pawn so
this is what Alexander is saying so an
April agrees he goes h6 and the now rook
the a to the so you don't have to
constantly keep an eye on this and
Knights to f5 putting pressure on the
bishop here Bishop to f4 and now Queen
to c6 most likely with the idea of just
trading of the white square bishops
alexei encode prevents it look the b2
enter now a6 further going with with the
same plan and now alex angkor plays d
captures on c5 and now well you could
play beat captures and c5 nothing wrong
with that maybe you can Castile bring
the rook to b8 to trade some rocks along
the B file nipa says that he prefers the
open C file his pawn is nicely protected
here and whitea does have some
weaknesses along the C file so maybe he
can take advantage of that so look the
b4 saying okay I'm gonna defend it by
attacking your bishop we have b5 and now
although the bishop is defended it's
hard hard to imagine how this bishop
will ever be activated again but that's
for for an effort to worry about we're
just here to enjoy the show
Bishop to d3 now again in defending
would a tactic because if Queen captures
you can capture here characters and
Queen captures and b5 is just winning
for Alex anko there's an attack on the
rook you cannot castle because the night
falls and let's say you do something
like this still Queen b7 again with a
double attack and there's not much you
can do here if Queen c5 Bishop e3 now
completely winning so there is poison to
the position so nipple just goes back of
course he doesn't allow this capture on
f5 and now Bishop back to be too
it's it's a timid move there there for
example maybe a better tribe would be
something like Knights the d4 to give up
the deponents III and to go queen g4 but
it's hard to evaluate this position and
what's actually going on here will black
go g6 will he go kinked f8 but either
way maybe it was a more ambitious try
for Alexei eco instead he goes back
Bishop to b2 and now he allows a nipple
to just play Knight to c6 that's the
problem probably when I to d4 was maybe
a better try and now the rook is under
attack if you move the rook you lose the
a3 pawn and that's a very important
point
if this pawn starts marching forward you
could have a lot of problems so here
Alex & Co instead goes Bishop sorry
Quinta e 2 he gives up the exchange but
it's not it's not all that bad because
nipple captures we have a captures here
and now Queen back to c7 and now he's
down the exchange but Nepos bishop also
isn't doing anything so it's like it's
like he's not down the exchange it's
like this bishop isn't even here
but that's only true if the bishop
remains there so rook to e1 by Alex
ankle strengthening the e5 pawn here now
he wants to go again the knight to d4
and Knights to b8 preparing to counter
94 with Knight to c6 so we have 94
Knight to c6 and only now Queen to g4
going after the pawn here
here Knight captures on d4 we have C
capture Sun before which exposes the C
to pawn but you do have to worry about
the g7 point so here Napo tried g6 g5
might be even better here because after
g6
here he basically gives Alex anko are
there what do you play here is white of
course the your first thought is just
you know capture that pawn and blacks
position shouldn't shouldn't be able to
withhold this but it's hard to calculate
everything that goes on in the position
the problem is if Bishop captures on g6
then okay if you capture of course Queen
captures here Queen blocks Queen capped
receiver you grabbed three points for
the for the piece that's compensation in
itself and Oh
white will have at least a draw here if
not more the problem is after Bishop
captures on g6 what if you play
something like Queen e7 what if you
Castle here do you want to give nipple
the the semi-open G file those are the
questions you have to be ready to answer
however it it it should be good for
white because of this rook to e3 move
probably something Alex saying who
missed in his calculations but still
hard hard to evaluate for example King
b7 getting out of the out of the trap
rook c3 Queen c7 and now Bishop back to
d3 you grab the pawn
blacks bishop here is still doing
nothing in the future moves like a5
feeling really worked for black because
opening up the position on the Queen
side now that the black King Castle
queenside is not something you want to
do and if you start piling up on the G
file Queen h5 you're gonna go Ruby g7
maybe try and double up here g3 and this
should be very solid it's it's it's hard
to see that you will actually be able to
break this so the this was definitely
the way for Alex anko to go but it's
hard to hard to play such a move in such
an important game and especially against
a poner po is just incredible in crazy
positions probably probably the best
player in crazy positions so here Alex &
Co played h5 which kind of does the same
thing for an echo it gives in the open
the semi open G file but without Alex &
Co actually grabbing any material and
after an epic Castle queenside now you
have the problem of this c2 upon hanging
not yet to you of course you don't want
to meet something like this
so f4 is played and now never goes kink
to b8 and now this this could be a
problem
so now c3 by like saying go and now you
have this position where compared to
that one you've given it for the semi
open G file but you don't have this rook
nicely placed on c3 rather it's on e one
doing nothing and you've given a nipple
a free way to activate his bishop back
into the game so definitely that Bishop
captures on g6 line was an improvement
but okay nepo continues Bishop b3 of
course he wants the trade off the dark
square bishop which he probably thought
was never gonna see the light of day
and now f5 by Alex ankle we have Bishop
to c4 and now Bishop back to c24 now
keeping an eye on the f5 pawn saying
that you're better fancy for is not that
big of a deal here
rook dg8 by nepo and now King f2 just
getting away from the G file and now a
five now nepo is not afraid to do this
as well he's feeling pretty safe here we
have B captures on a5 and here neppo has
to decide what to do and it's not an
easy decision although he's at the
exchange White's position is great this
is a massive Center he still has the
best pair the rook is well for now not
doing anything but it could be doing
something so here never played Queen
captures on a5 allowing the screen
captures on f7 move and that's maybe not
the the absolute best way to go about it
the absolute best way would be something
like King b7 and now shifting the rook
here and try to pick up the pawn with
the rock of course white would not allow
that looked looked a8 and now let's say
g4 and you have this position where
anything could happen but it's
definitely black who should still be
better because he is up material and but
it's hard to find how you will actually
do something about this for example
maybe maybe if you put your pieces
absolutely on the best squares and then
maybe bust open the position with f6 or
something like that you don't have to
worry about white grabbing this pawn
even if you move the rook let's say you
don't have to worry about this because
you always just bring back the rook and
then you you will you know have a lot of
things to do along the H file but it's
an extremely complicated game and Napo
decides against the net po decides to go
for Queen captures on a5 we have Queen
captures on f7 and now Queen - a - just
going after the bishops here and it
seems like a black black is completely
winning however Queen captures on e6 by
Alex and Coe and the now with the Queen
having access to the b6 square there's
not much you can do here never captured
and c2 but now just Queen b6 check King
to c8 and Queen the c6 check and of
course here never when
a queen bee sucks checking here Quincy
six checking v8 and after Queen b6 check
it was in this position that the players
agree to a draw but also it's a draw by
threefold repetition so not much you can
do here you don't have time for
something like rook to c1 because you're
just getting made it here captures king
of three check here and let's say look
the g4 is mate so you don't have a way
of improving your position because
everything is just hanging this hangs
this hangs so not nothing to be done
here but really an exciting game and a
really really awesome for NAPA that he
went for the French defense like I said
most likely because the only game they
ever played was a night of Sicilian and
never wanted to avoid that against Alex
& Co so instead we got this really
awesome line where like I said Alex & Co
had had two chances where he could have
gone for a more ambitious try but it's
always a question in chess do you go for
the more ambitious try and you know
expose yourself become vulnerable like
for example what Fabi did yesterday
against ding he played an incredible
game really really awesome and then he
did have that one chance where he had
that solution to Brooke to e5 but he he
decided to not to go for it and in the
end is being prevailed here also Alex
and Co had some tries like that Bishop
to g6 also denied the d4 sacrificing the
c3 pawn but India and the other game
ended in a row but a very exciting game
and I'm very happy that that the game
happened the way the way did sir yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
let's check out I don't know if I will
have time to show any more games from
round 3 so let's just check out the
standings after round 3 as today's a
rest day
so a shearing first Janna Punisher
machine wash Alegre and one cow are then
with point and a half Fabiana Corwin and
Alexandre Gouda shook with one point
ding clear and an expiry and kiddo
Alex echo like I said it's only one out
of three for ding but what a point it is
just in case you miss that game I don't
recommend you you miss it I will put a
link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you see so do
check it out the the greatest game ever
so yeah I would like to thank backers
been Android Reverend Edgar
Cottonelle Anthony Nez goes and William
Peck for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video serie thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Vita candidates
tournament until it finishes so thank
you all I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your Friday and for
the end let's just check out this
awesome photo once again there you have
it see you soon